[Music]
thanks everybody
okay so uh my talk is entitled
asynchronous programming in r
uh but i have to give a little
disclaimer it's sort of but not
really about asynchronous programming in
our um
when i was developing the materials for
uh for this talk
um i realized i couldn't like
asynchronous programming is such a huge
topic i would
have a hard time uh really explaining it
in the way that
i found satisfying in this in 20 minutes
um
and then i thought about all these other
topics that come along with asynchronous
programming
in in my experience in the stuff that i
work on so there's also
parallelism concurrency and event driven
programming
so let me define these for you in case
you're not really familiar with these so
asynchronous programming is when you
call a function it doesn't block so
normally when you're writing your r code
and you're running it
you know it steps through it does each
thing and if you do something that takes
a long time like
uh let's say you tell article download a
file it stops there
and then once the file is downloaded it
continues and your
your script continues to run uh if in an
asynchronous
program you might if if there's an
asynchronous download what it would do
is
you you're essentially it would say hey
go download this file some other
thing in the computer go download the
file and the code would keep running
and then later you check hey is my file
downloaded or maybe you might say or it
might
run a callback and tell you hey the file
is done now that's asynchronous
programming
parallelism is when you do multiple
things at the same time that's very
common on modern computers with multiple
cores
concurrency is when it seems like you're
doing multiple things at the same time
but
you might not actually be doing multiple
things at the same time so
if you're familiar with javascript in a
web browser that's
single threaded and it can seem like a
web page is doing a lot of things at
once
but it's really splitting its time in
between uh different tasks and switching
between them very quickly so it seems
like
it just seems like it's doing uh things
in parallel
uh and finally there's uh event driven
programming and
where you have events that occur there
might be some
outside signal and that causes somebody
some code to run
so i was thinking about this and uh you
know asynchronous programming was too
big and so i thought i'd
try to talk about all of these a little
bit or at least actually a common thread
that runs through all of them
which is um a package called later
and that later was originally created by
joe chang
and um i don't know if it's coincidence
but it was a conversation with him that
helped me settle on this topic
so thanks joe um
all right so i'm gonna show you a demo
here of um
let me see if i can make this go away
try to make this large enough to
i'll be sort wow
semi-visible all right so let's say well
you don't have to see the specific code
the exact code here
let's say i'm creating a data frame
called data
and uh i've populated it with some x and
y values
and this plot magically appeared
in our studio here and if i modify it so
i square all the x values
um that plot redraws and now i have a
you know a parabola shape here
and i can do the same with y and if i
restore data to what it was before
um it it re-plots again
so uh there's something going on here
it's not any magic from our studio
the ide but um it involves
uh involves later this is and what
you're seeing here is sort of
uh at least from the user perspective
this is event this is event different
programming so i'm not telling it to
replot
every time i change data but every time
i change data
it causes this plotting code to
re-execute and i ran that actually
ahead of time before i started this talk
and i'll show it to you in a little bit
but let's talk about uh let's talk about
what
the later package does so later provides
something called an
event loop event loop is a queue of
functions that will run in the future
and it's uh it's very similar to set
timeout in javascript if you're familiar
with javascript
um and if this is confusing to you i
will
show you a very simple example of how
later is used
so uh you load the later package i'm
setting a flag
to tell me when i'm to signal when
something is done
and then i say later run this function
here
which prints out a message and updates
the flag
after five seconds and then at the end
i'll say
well i'm not done run now it means keep
running
these functions that are in this event
loop in this in this queue
so let's do this let's run this stuff
here
and uh you won't be surprised to see
that after five seconds
it prints out this message hello world
and
i know there's people out there who've
already figured out how to write this in
about six lines of code
to implement this so this part is this
part is not
really that difficult but what later
what you might be a little bit more
surprised to see is that if i run the
same code here
and i don't do run now and we wait five
seconds
it will also print hello world so uh
later has some c code that runs and
when your r console is idle when your
r's when r the call stack is empty and
you're not running any anything else
it will continue running this event loop
okay so that plot watching code that i
show or
that uh we saw the plot watcher before
and this is the code so what it does
is first uh this is it's it's pretty
simple so i'm just setting data to know
on the last value to null
and then i have this function called
plotwatch
and uh if if the data is not null
and if it's different from the last
value then plot it
and then update the last value so that's
all really standard r code
the thing that's different is right here
i call
later plot watch so it's this this
function
uh is rescheduling itself to run after a
quarter second
and then uh after we define the function
we have to kick it off we have to get it
started by by invoking the function once
and then uh this and it's doing what's
sort of um i guess you might call it a
polling loop where it just it keeps
running every quarter of a second and
every time
data changes it executes the plotting
code
so later also has a c api this is
important when you're doing a lot of
this
when you're doing asynchronous
programming because a lot of times you
have to interface with external
libraries
so from c code you can call later to
schedule a c function to execute there's
a c
function later and that c function
that you've scheduled x you can in turn
call an r function
and uh and also a very another very
important point is that this function
the later function is thread safe so you
can have another thread
schedule something to run uh it can
schedule an r function to run
okay so that's a brief overview of later
um
it's what it does is is pretty simple
but it unlocks a lot of possibilities so
here's some real world
uses of later and i'm going to show you
some stuff
uh some demos and explain how some of
these things work
uh so one thing that we've worked on
recently is a websocket client
websocket is a protocol for um basically
for communicating between
computers um through a well
through a fancy web server so uh
this is this is how it's used so i
create a websocket i say websocket new
and connect to the server
and then i tell it uh
hey when you receive a message invoke
this function
so this is uh this is a event-driven
programming here
but it doesn't actually call this
function right away and what it does
this function will print out hey i've
received this
this whatever the message is
all right so i've set up that uh event
handler
uh and then at the end i can say i can
tell it to send
hello world so let's see this in action
now what it's doing is not very
surprising will not be very surprising
um so if you haven't if you
can't see it this is the same code that
you saw before
and uh so i sent hello world and what i
received back is that same string
reversed so
it's talking to a websocket server that
you know takes a string reverses it and
sends it back so it's just doing
this really basic transformation on it
all right now the way that this works
internally is use is used as polling
similar to that plot watcher that we
or the data watcher that we had before
so um we have this arrow representing
time
and uh several times per second we're
doing we're polling and we're checking
for any if there's any input output that
has happened
on this websocket now at some arbitrary
point in time
uh in r you might tell it to send a
message send hello world
and that gets that puts it in this
output queue but the output
that output queue isn't handled uh until
this polling event here and when we get
to the polling event that actually calls
out to a c plus plus library that does
you know handles all this input and
output stuff
and it sends a message to the server um
when that happens the server sends a
message back
uh and then that that message sits in
the input queue
uh until the next polling event happens
and when that when that occurs then it
calls the on message handler and it
prints out
they have received this hello world
reversed
and i just uh in this particular slide
the blue indicates that this is this is
something that was triggered by the
polling event
that that later provided okay so that's
how the websocket package works at least
that's how the cran version of websocket
works on github there's actually the
development version
of websocket has been changed
to use threads actually let me show you
one thing real quick about this
so if you're familiar with this sort of
programming you know that
um polling is not like the ideal way to
do this there's a little bit of latency
that can occur between these events here
um and it also if you're doing a lot of
polling really quick it can
it can use cpu time that shouldn't be
that
really shouldn't be used um but it's
simple to implement
so the the development version of
websocket is threaded
this is uh and so there's two threads
there's this main r thread
and then it launches another thread that
handles the input and output
all right so if i tell it to send the
message from and that that happens in r
uh what it does is it calls the c
function or c plus plus function
send which is thread safe which cues
which tells the i o thread hey
i want you to send this message and the
i o thread at this point will be idle
and so it will hand it will deal with
this request right away
send the message to the server server
send something back
and um if the authority is idle then it
will immediately
use later to tell the r thread
uh this is the c function later to tell
arthur hey handle this message that i
just got
and if the arthritis is hitting idle at
that point it'll it'll print it out
if our thread is busy at that time um
like represented by that red bar there
then it will
it will wait until it's uh it's done
doing whatever computation it's doing
and then it will
handle that cued function all right so
that's uh
so these are two common ways of handling
input and output
uh asynchronous io with polling and with
threads all right uh
now another use that we have is a web
server called the http uv
this uh this package you might have
heard of it before it has an awkward
name
um it underlies shiny and plumber
and and to start a web server it's
actually very simple you just say start
server you give it the
um the port you want to listen on and
then this function here
which it's a callback that gets invoked
when
an event happens an incoming request
occurs so when you get an incoming http
request
it calls this function and passes in uh
this object called
rec and in this case i'm just having a
create a web page that has the time and
the path that was requested and then
it returns some other http stuff along
with that so you can you can imagine
that you can use this
you could use this um in all sorts of
different ways
you can it just will execute an r
function whenever you get an http
request
so um i'll show you this real quick in
action
what it will do is also not surprising
since i've already talked about it
um it gives you the time and the path
that was requested so that was just
slash i could say our studio
oops your studio conf and then it prints
out that path there
um all right now i'm just gonna show you
some other cool stuff
um some fun stuff so
uh i also started before this or before
i started doing the talk i've started up
a
another http application um
which provides a remote r
console a repl so i can you know can say
you know one one plus one sum of one
through ten
and this is this this uh is causing our
code to execute so this is actually
using websocket connection it's
uh the the web browser sends this string
over the websocket
and then the r process gets the string
it evaluates it
captures the output and sends it back so
that's what's happening here
the interesting thing about this is it's
actually running in the same r process
that we've been doing all the rest of
this stuff
so if i change data to be
let's try say data x
data x squared
that did not work at all oh there it
goes okay
all right so uh this is
this is running in the same art process
um
all right and of course you're familiar
with shiny shiny is based on http uv
so i can run this shiny app here which
is displaying the same
the same data uh and i can if i
randomize it
it'll you know if i click this button
randomize it does you've seen this sort
of thing with a shiny app
and again these are these are connected
here so when i randomize the data i'm
using
poor shiny programming practices where
i'm modifying a global variable
um but for this demo it's good um and
it's it's changing that plot right there
okay so um so that's a taste of some of
the things that are possible there's one
other thing i want to show
using a package called cremote which is
this headless
headless chrome web browser package
which uses a lot of asynchronous
programming
and i won't go into depth about it right
now i just want to show some other fun
stuff that you can do
so i can start a promote session
i'll navigate to the same application
and i'll take a screenshot of it and
when it takes a screenshot
it actually will cause that screenshot
to appear in this viewer pane here this
is this is not
the shiny up here this is a screenshot
of a shiny app if you see i can sort of
drag this around here and just to prove
to you that it's actually
oops so i tried to run it in our studio
but our studio console is blocked
i have to run it over here because this
one is driven by later
this is a this is you can get a view
into the headless browser
and then you can sort of interact with
it here i can click on randomize over
there
and then if i take a screenshot of it
again you'll see
that sorry i did it again
okay
if i take a screenshot again
you'll see that that button is sort of
grayed which indicates that it was
selected which is what i was doing
over there all right so let's uh
that's the fun demos all right so let's
get back to
what we saw here so we saw we saw this
web socket server that
reverses strings a web server that shows
you the time
a web server with this remote r console
which you can use while you're running a
shiny application
running a shiny app we were watching had
this plot data watcher
and we have this headless chrome client
all these used later that's what makes
it all possible for them to run
concurrently
and uh and this is all in one r process
okay so uh one thing i
i took a look at the uh the later cran
page and i
i looked at the package that we're using
later and one thing i i noticed was that
even though it's been out for a couple
of years
there's not that many packages that use
it and all of them are maintained by
people that work at our studio
so uh i'm hoping that you know we have a
lot of this knowledge
internally from from like we've got
battle scars working on this stuff but
hopefully
um hopefully if you're working on
you know if you're working on async
programming or parallelism or
concurrency
and event driven programming this will
be useful for you
and uh i have a the url here it's not
the materials aren't actually up there
right now but they will be
thank you
thanks winston that was fascinating uh i
can assure you that i
am using your work i have
promote writing on a scheduled basis to
take photographs of
of the work my colleagues are doing
um for those of you that are leaving
we are just carrying on with questions
so please do so quietly if you can
question number one um
does later deal with the issues of tail
call stack optimization that that could
arise from the
recursive event loop format
uh it does not that's actually a great
question uh you have to be i want i
wanted to mention it but i didn't have
time that
if you're going to be calling the
function itself you have to make sure
not to create any closures
that uh uh that will keep increasing the
depth of the calls tax you have to
create
a function outside of your function that
you're calling
okay and the second question is if later
is running and you want to run another
what happened oh there we go and you
want another run another line of code
does the new line you are running jump
ahead
of later or does it wait those five
seconds to run
so if you uh it will jump ahead of later
so after five seconds have elapsed even
whatever you've written whatever you've
done before um
it won't wait an extra five seconds
it'll wait for five seconds total unless
ours occupied at the moment that that
callback would occur
thank you and last question um it's
getting quite a few votes
is there a way to prioritize different
asynchronous
um streams different asynchronous is
there a way to prioritize different
asynchronous streams um
that i not sure fully understand the
question so i'm sorry i can't answer
that
if you ask the question you just want to
shout out and clarify
no okay winston thank you very much this
was fascinating
thank you
[Music]